here we go against yeah Burt yeah he
doesn't have the best of ratings at the
moment which is quite similar to my
situation so I'm on minus 4i are the
last two games I lost pretty miserably
so I hope for improvement here playing
it in a simple way edge and want I just
want a simple position
it's not very ambitious what I'm doing
but John still keep it simple it's not a
bad idea so what is this if I cheek
night to your form yeah okay let's let's
keep things and ask him what he is doing
I cannot go a three-year that it would
be just to weakening be three especially
would be weakened maybe I can play this
yeah I don't like I don't know if I want
to go away three and let's do this I
mean now I'm having be three protected
and e5 Knight f5 that that cannot be
good now maybe can do that units it
looks a bit strange to get the Nigeria
fire pit okay plays in a place in a more
far more solid way so let's take
yeah okay so I was thinking this may be
44 maybe this is too ambitious but I'd
like to blunt this Bishop down I weight
and maybe had no now before night a
force attacking the bishop I was
thinking before Night Moves Bishop takes
a six but ok night a form is attacking
by bishops up it's not that wasn't on
but maybe still be four night a for
Bishop be one that would have been
interesting but Bishop reform ok maybe
f3 wasn't that bad at least it was quick
I've got quite a bit of a time advantage
him
all right it's not so easy fam those
points there okay he decided to allow me
this um okay yeah I go there but it
gives him this b3 counterplay so still
before and now if we might just take
actually mmm interesting
yeah like 90 for every for Bishop reform
and then I'm double attacked sorry about
that okay maybe get out of night a for
stuff possibly Bishop edge form e for I
have 90 form and then F form that should
be ok yeah Chad let's take and now if or
I can play there is no no tactic at
least not tactic that I see he very
often I of course finds tactics that I
did not see before beforehand mm okay
maybe Bishop aged father then whoopty to
hmm that's annoying this Bishop there
Quincy one Queen III as my idea all
right so it's not easy this position for
both of us to play not easy he has
active pieces but it's not a not
entirely clear how he how he M
coordinates them well
yeah it was interesting I saw that idea
if it takes King g7 it's a bit a bit
problematic so I'm going back night
would have been basically trapped down
on age 6 okay so Bishop d2 or is this
stupid I would like to put it to e3 only
three may be here look at this Bishop e3
92 this is this is a good setup actually
coordinating my pieces finally 92 is
asking the bishop as well where it is
going to go that sets active but quite
weakening
I can do here right oh no oh no I don't
see one there wow I didn't I had a total
hallucination there oh wow okay and that
was that was then quite unintended cool
should she fall maybe coming
okay so isn't there something here I
don't believe it here checking here how
is this going to hold for him time
warning for chicks there and check no
and Quincy form for Queen f7 and that
might be good and Roxy six his king
should be more of a problem than mine
solo okay Quincy six rook d6 check Queen
B seven maybe this thing checks on the
seventh I as a counter chicken be
counter check
check check check I don't see jack no no
I'm not another tell me I'm losing this
game this is a shame or no ah yeah come
on that should really win one of those
once in a while if you give he was
completely completely over stretching
there and certainly had a win with his
King being so exposed but I did not find
it i even had more time on the clock so
how do I win this this this is right
this is rook c6 is swinging out who came
I child I played Quincy six jobs Jeff
how am i winning Queen d5 and over I
it's so easy it's so easy and I have
more time leave the thing what would
annoys me sometimes against against the
yard podium in the noise the wrong way
but he plays for win in every position
even in positions meds totally
unwarranted yeah he just should just
sometimes take a draw and be glad with
it and he plays yeah I like him yeah
like only that's just one way one way to
play always forward which is attractive
sometimes to watch but interest in
totally undetected it's just bad chairs
sometimes and you should punish it yeah
this is something that I must punish and
I don't I don't see those those
childlike wins them yeah okay the
problem was i thought he and i didn't
see that this is a counter counter made
threat white is still winning here but
chat it is more more difficult and here
they're certainly check some kind of
some kind of thing
yeah by now I was down on the clock this
is also just a very good end game and
cannot defend his pawns yeah I really
hate to lose against is that such an
objective pledge is just you should just
be glad with an eco position and and not
kill himself and if he kills himself you
have to pick up those pieces and here it
was very easily doable I'll say even
more know now this was okay I just have
to check him on the six back here this
is this is easy check yeah amazing that
this is a draw and he has this counter
idea here queen bee aid was even
stronger attacking this rook check check
their live you just just he just gets
hunted down he weakened himself
voluntarily here with f5 and stuff like
that okay well thanks for watching